hello everyone I'm an email Weaver a
partner manager with Google cloud and
I'm Shanklin living a product manager
with Google cloud coming to your life
from our homes and basement and thanks
for taking the time to join us today for
the social event we've that content
organized in three sections one why
Google cloud for high-performance
computing or HPC - some of our product
capabilities that support HPC and three
highlighting some of our awesome
partners that work with us to make our
customers successful if there's one
thing that we want you to walk away with
it's a Google cloud democratizes HPC and
we want to enable HPC the Google way
through our partnerships and product
portfolio let's start with HPC for
Google cloud we want to share some
real-world examples of HPC in action and
how GCP is contributing one of the
topics that is top of mind for us and
for many of us is koban 19 and the
scientific research being performed to
develop diagnostic tools and a possible
vaccine a number of different scientific
efforts are underway there are teams
working on discovering new drugs for
treating kovin 19 patients others are
focused on genomics developing better
techniques for genetic screening there
are teams that are running molecular
simulations to better understand how the
virus impacts human cells and the
effects various treatments can have all
of these problems are HPC problems where
you have to perform large numbers of
computations and in some there's also a
large amount of data involved making HPC
even more critical for completing these
workloads in a timely manner Google has
joined hands with industry partners to
create the koban 19 HPC consortium this
consortium has gathered now more than 60
projects with hundreds of peda flops
millions of CPU cores and tens of
thousands of GPUs dedicated to kovin 19
research in some sense applying HPC to
such research problems is not new
however
is new is that this is and this is an
unprecedented situation one that
requires rapid response and unfettered
collaboration across research groups
drawn from academia and industry
depending on the scenarios researchers
need access to new technologies in some
cases accelerators like GPUs and TP use
so they can run their simulations and
machine learning models faster in other
cases they need access to new software
last but not least given the
experimentation driven nature of the
research users need on-demand access to
resources since they don't know which
project is going to lead to success and
they need the ability to adapt Lea
allocate resources as needed how do you
overcome these challenges we believe
cloud computing in general and Google
Cloud specifically has solutions and
tools to address them Google cloud is
playing a small part and I want to
emphasize that Google clouds
contribution pales in comparison to the
efforts that researchers and other
individuals are putting in nonetheless
Google cloud is helping where we can let
me tell you more about a specific covin
19 project where we're playing a part
one team at Harvard Medical School is
screening ultra large libraries of
chemical compounds to accelerate the
drug discovery process using a grant of
Google research credits for the first
protein target of interest the team at
Harvard built on the scaleable
processing of GCP and slurm a scheduler
that Google Cloud supports to run 80,000
cores at the same time and to analyze
more than 1 billion compounds in 5 days
using GCP and Google credits to scale up
its computations the team is able to
conduct ultra large virtual screenings
much faster than ever before
as of May 2020 the team has targeted 16
proteins with 40 target sites and run 35
billion docking instances using 750
million CPU hours next my teammates
shine will share how
Google cloud helps other organizations
facing similar HPC challenges you may be
wondering how to lovin these challenges
that Annie talked about in the context
covert research are relevant to you your
users and organization now whether
you're a large organization with a
significant HPC budget on a smaller
startup that is just starting out there
are always projects where you and your
users need to collaborate better there
are going to be cases where you want to
experiment with new technologies so that
you can bring new products to market
much much faster and lastly you always
want to have the flexibility and ability
to respond faster to changing business
needs and do not want to be constrained
by typical procurement cycles in short
you want to be agile what is he working
with many many customers is that many of
these challenges are even more
pronounced for customers from commercial
and industrial background more so than
research institutions that is primarily
because they need for security controls
is higher and typical procurement
policies are not designed with agility
in mind just as Google Cloud is able to
address these challenges for covert
researchers it can help customers in
mainstream industries as well let's look
at some specifics one of the biggest
challenges customers face is the fairly
rigid infrastructure that you deploy on
premises the chart in the slide is an
illustration of the business impact of
having a fix in infrastructure when you
have infrastructure with fixed capacity
there are going to be times when the
infrastructure is underutilized and more
importantly there are going to be times
when the infrastructure is
oversubscribed which means some of your
users are going to face extended wait
times which translates either into delay
products or the inability to respond
quickly to new market needs this is all
in addition to the challenge of having
an internal structure that can quickly
go out of date and not meet the needs of
your users we talked about how HP seems
our structure is deployed on premises
and some of the challenges with Google
cloud you can address all of those
challenges
first and foremost you have access to
elastic compute and storage which means
you get to provision the resources that
are light sized for your application
nothing more and nothing less second you
also get access to new technologies be
it new software technologies or new
hardware platforms a group in your
organization may wanted to poised for a
new algorithm on a new application that
they're developing and with cloud you're
able to do that in an on-demand manner
whereas in on-premises you lightweight
multiple weeks or multiple months
deployed GPUs and then figure out who is
going to go manage that infrastructure
lastly Google cloud also makes data
sharing with internal and external
collaborators easy and secure by having
all of your data centrally collected and
curated you can effectively and securely
share it with users that Nina need to
have access to it but also you retain
control you're able to deep publish an
access when a user or a group of users
don't need access to data anymore or you
can very quickly protion access when you
users join your organization a number of
customers today use Google cloud for
those very same reasons customers across
industries ranging from life sciences to
financial services to chip design
together modeling all use Google cloud
today that is an addition to a number of
research institutions that use Google
cloud today and get the benefits of a
globally available secure scalable and
on-demand infrastructure you can find
details about these and other customers
at cloud.google.com slash customers with
that let me pivot and talk a little bit
about some of the products and services
that are available to customers on our
platform the most critical aspect for
HPC applications is having a highly
reliable and scalable infrastructure
that is delivered as an on-demand
service to that in Google cloud
infrastructure as a service products
span the breadth and depth of what users
need
Capel engine which is
Virtual Machines product in Google cloud
provides flexible size virtual machines
that start up in seconds while also
allowing for custom configuration of
processor memory and purses and storage
to best suit the needs of your
applications computer gbm's also support
Linux and Windows operating systems that
by allowing you to move applications
that that need both Linux and Windows
operating systems to Google clock you
have the flexibility to choose between
end Intel and AMD processors you also
get again a choice of processors that
are optimized for high clock speed and
vertically scaling applications versus
those that are optimized for scale out
applications there are a number of
sessions in the computer but the details
of the compute engine virtual machines
product i'd highly recommend watching
some of those gen is backed by google
clouds high performance software-defined
networking the computer gene network is
VMS between themselves as well as we
beyond the internet with high throughput
low latency networking similarly google
cloud offers an array of storage
products ranging from object storage to
file based storage we'll cover some of
the details of the storage and
networking products in the subsequent
slides there's one specific virtual
machine type that I want to highlight a
new product that we launched last year
c2 or short for computer optimized
virtual machines is a new VM type that
is optimized for HPC applications it
provides three point eight yards of
sustained clock speed it provides full
transparency into the underlying server
architecture that by enabling advanced
performance tuning it also supports up
to three terabytes of local SSD for
high-speed ephemeral storage and
provides 32 GB PS of network through C
two VMs also include a number of
software features that HPC applications
can take advantage of for example it
supports new aware applications which
enables applique
chance to further improve their
performance by reducing memory access
times in our to better support HPC
workloads we also launched a capability
that gives customers control over the
physical placement of the in virtual
machines when it comes to internode
latency in an HPC cluster lots of
physics come into play the further apart
your nodes are the more time it is going
to take for packets to be exchanged
between the nodes in your cluster there
are algorithms often referred to as
tightly coupled algorithms that are very
sensitive to this latency as a result we
now give you the ability to set a policy
that instructs our placement algorithms
to place the virtual machines as close
as possible and in most cases that is
going to be within the same physical
data center lag so that you get the
lowest possible latency possible
what are the reasons customers want to
move to cloud so that they can optimize
their spin and get the most value for
their cloud spent there are quite a few
mechanisms available in Google cloud
that allows you to optimize your TCO but
I want to highlight a couple that really
speak to the way that Google cloud in
general has been architected and
engineered from ground up to give you
the flexibility the first our custom
machine types the ability to create
virtual machines with the amount of CPU
and memory that you need while you may
be familiar with predefined virtual
machines that that you may have used in
a different router environment which by
the way is optimized for providers
efficiency then customers TCO
in Google cloud by adjusting a slider
you can choose the amount of CPU and
memory that you need and Google Cloud is
the only place where that is possible
next Google Cloud has a feature called
sustained use discounts that
automatically gives you bigger discounts
the more you use your virtual machines
there is no custom policy that you need
to set as a user
there is no subscription there is no
special flag that you need to activate
it
just use your virtual machines and the
more you use it you get a bigger
discount these two capabilities are in
addition to some of the other
capabilities that you'll see elsewhere
as were committed use discounts which
gives you a bigger discount if you come
in for a longer duration of time
preemptable VMs which gives you up to
80% of discount which is great for
workloads that can tolerate failures
CPUs are great for a broad set of
workloads that's why we all you CPUs
however there are algorithms that
benefit from the massive amount of
parallelism that accelerators such as
GPUs offer on Google cloud in addition
to offering AMD and Intel CPUs we
provide NVIDIA GPUs that Annie will talk
about in a little bit and the custom
design and built ASIC for machine
learning called TP use on the one hand
GPUs enable graphics visualization and
can also be used as general-purpose
computation units for speeding up your
algorithms including machine learning
algorithms on the other hand TP use
short
tensor processing units are specifically
designed for machine learning use cases
in mind by Google and help accelerate
the time to solution for AI and machine
learning applications
storage services are a critical part of
cloud infrastructure and play a very
important role for HPC applications
Google cloud provides a breadth of
storage options some offered from Google
and some offered from our partners such
as ddn NetApp and customers can deploy
their choice choice to the HPC asks they
can deploy a scale or file server using
cloud file store if they need a POSIX
compliant file a parallel file system
they can deploy lustre file system that
is provided by ddn and is available on
our marketplace the pike storage volumes
from their tab all gone for fill out
network attached storage now in all of
these cases customers can use Google
Cloud storage for cost-efficient cold
storage of data irrespective of what
storage system is in use in the HPC
cluster finally they can also use data
transfer tools that are provided by
Google to move data from their
on-premises environment into Google
Cloud storage and then use that as a
staging ground to hydrate their HPC
clusters not infrastructure can be HPC
ready without strong networking
capabilities particularly for tightly
coupled applications as I said earlier
the fully software-defined network that
Google Cloud operates provides all the
policy driven controls that we you would
expect from a WAN and Sdn but at the
same time provides la performance that
you need for your network performance
sensitive applications Google Cloud
currently supports up to 32 gig up de
pierres of VMs and up 200 GB pierre's of
through port 4 GPUs
the software-defined network gives
customers controller networking policies
such as firewall controls a global VPC
and an architecture for multi-region
applications you can now run API
applications in Google Cloud
we support both open MPR and Intel MPI
applications and in fact we just
recently published a set of optimization
scripts and on a guide for tuning your
application on Google Cloud you can find
those tools in Google clouds github
with that I want to be mindful of the
time and hand it back over to Annie for
her to talk about Google cloud spot
nurse and how they help you be
successful on our platform thanks Jen
for that helpful and comprehensive
discussion of how GCP enables HPC
through our products next let's talk
about how our partnerships enable HPC
workloads a typical HPC workload has a
few key components some of these are
necessarily and best served by a cloud
service provider like Google cloud such
as pricing models accelerators and the
fundamentals compute storage networking
etc other layers of the stack are often
domain specific examples include
applications tools libraries and
management platforms it is not possible
for Google alone to tackle the wide
array of offerings and requirements that
exist at these levels we are able to
provide complete end-to-end solutions
for HPC thanks to our partners our
partners some of which I will cover in
greater detail in the following slides
complement and complete our native stack
with their know-how and technology we
are able to deliver end-to-end solutions
to enable our customers to quickly and
easily run HPC workloads on GCP the
first partner I'd like to highlight is
scan em D which has built the market
leading open source scheduler slurm
google cloud teamed up with skadam DS to
release a set of tools that make it
easier to launch the slurm workload
manager on compute engine and to expand
your existing cluster dynamically when
you need extra resources this
integration was built by the experts at
scan MD in accordance with slurm best
practices Google cloud is the only
public cloud provider for which stat MD
has built these optimized slurm scripts
thanks to our partnership for those
interested in trying out the scripts
today please scan the QR code on the
slide to be redirected to a code lab
that will teach you how to run a slurm
cluster on TCP in March of this year
Scott MD released version 3 of the slurm
on GCD scripts which are available on
its github page please visit
codelab Scott M DS github and reach out
to your cloud account team to learn more
about slurm on GCP
the next partner I'd like to highlight
is Nvidia we are proud to offer five GPU
families on GCP with a new GPU family
the a100 coming soon on Google cloud
marketplace we have 50 plus Nvidia
Google cloud or NGC containers available
and 600 plus GPU accelerated HPC
applications also for HPC Nvidia is
recently released an SDK that supports
GPU accelerated HPC modeling and
simulation applications you can learn
more about our partnership in the Nvidia
including how we're enabling industry
specific use cases at the power of 2 dot
solutions last but not least you can
find sessions presented by Googlers at
GCC 2020 at the short link on the slide
we set up our GPUs and pass-through mode
so that you can experience bare metal
performance and with the flexibility of
cloud you can attach up to 8 GPUs to
your instance and mix and match
different Google cloud resources to
build your tailored infrastructure and
of course our typical features apply you
can preempt a GPU and take advantage of
per second billing and sustained use
discounts google cloud offers a range of
NVIDIA GPUs whether you need
cost-effective inference or scale up or
scale out training as I mentioned
earlier we have a suite of five GPUs
available today kad started machine
learning training workloads years ago P
100 B 100 our top-of-the-line GPUs for
high-end training P 44 are great for
inference did you know that we were the
first hyper scale cloud to launch with
these GPUs we are also the only public
cloud that has T 4 GPUs available
globally we're also excited to announce
forthcoming support from the new NVIDIA
MP architecture and the Nvidia a 100
tensor core GPU next I want to tell you
about rescale rescale offers an
industry-leading HPC management platform
that runs on public cloud infrastructure
solving the common challenges of
implementing and managing cloud and
on-premise HPC infrastructure resources
in enterprise environments at the end of
last year rescale completed an
integration of its platform with Google
Cloud and we launched a joint offering
key segments that we are targeting with
rescale include electronic design
automation manufacturing and healthcare
and life sciences you can learn more
about rescale and GCP at the link on the
slide
Raziel offers a single portal that can
manage all of your HPC applications and
data the portal runs on top of Google
Cloud infrastructure allowing you to
quickly ramp up your consumption
rescales portfolio features 400-plus
leading HPC applications and provides
extensive coverage of critical workloads
for aerospace automotive industrial
manufacturing semiconductor and energy
sectors customers can take advantage of
rescales focus solution for HPC combined
with the customizable practically
limitless infrastructure of Google Cloud
rescale has years of experience
partnering with software and hardware
providers to pursue HPC workloads and
enterprise accounts with its direct
sales force it also has a team of HPC
hardware and software experts ready to
assist you in accelerating migration of
your workflows to the cloud again you
can learn more about rescale on GCP
today at rescale comm / GCP last but not
least I'd like to highlight one of our
storage partners that focuses on HPC
workloads ddn CDN has an offering
available on our google cloud
marketplace called EXA scalar cloud EXO
scalar cloud is a scaleable parallel
file system purpose-built for AI HPC and
other big data workloads ideally suited
for dynamic pay-as-you-go applications
from rapid simulation and prototyping to
cloud bursting peak HPC workloads excess
scalar cloud helps maximize storage
performance and cost effectiveness with
gzp the marketplace offering also
features 24 by 7 support to learn more
you can visit our marketplace today or
contact cloud @ DD n com
as I shared at the top this session if
there's one thing we want you to walk
away with it's this google cloud
democratizes HPC and we want to enable
HPC the Google way through our
partnerships and product portfolio if
you'd like to learn more about our HPC
products and partnerships here are
recommendations for related sessions to
help augment your understanding thank
you for your time and attention we
really appreciate it